Like I say, it's, you know, life's a
mystery going forward. The science
looking back. When you look back, we go,
we can all connect every single dot.
It's mathematical, scientific how we got
to this table right here.
We got plans for this afternoon, but
we're not sure what's going to happen.
But everything looking back, it's it's
it's all connected if we go back and
look at it. And there's a whole lot of I
thought that was the end. Well, it was
the end, but it was the beginning of
this thing. or I caught that red light
and therefore made me 60 seconds later
to get to that cafe where I met that
movie producer or that woman who became
my wife or whatever that is. It'll make
sense at the time.